with the world in Flames death became  merciful friend in a time of more  alliances were forged  new arms developed  Hitler's secret weapons were geared up  for final victory as fanatic scientists  and created the most horrible weapon  gevalt  when you leave a coupla sugar mama TL  some can lead us to an illusion from a  public asked to present he'll correct in  the sauce  hello postions I'm emotionally the god  Papa have been Hagar's insertion  involved a beacon in hives  let's talk Maris Bhuvana  seems nothing is under attack  got the mode of several terrorist  attacks taking place throughout  these are sharks but they can fly  time for talk [ __ ]  you  Daniel 15 ataxia Tassie Byron Azazel  Jonah see independent side by